[Music]
there are new developments in taylor
swift's legal showdown today her mother
became emotional while testifying
against the former radio DJ who Taylor
says groped her PT aligns Sophie she
lacy was in the courtroom Taylor Swift's
mom Andrea broke down in tears on the
stand this afternoon after Taylor had
told her about the alleged groping
incident
Andrea testified that quote I was upset
to the extent that I felt like I wanted
to vomit and cry at the same time
Taylor swiveled around in her chair to
face her mom head-on during the
testimony she seemed really angry and
upset at the line of questioning being
thrown at Andrea including questioning
why she wanted to keep the incident
private Taylor's attorney wasn't talking
outside of court but inside her legal
team spent the majority of the morning
questioning the credibility of David
Mueller he's the former radio DJ who
Taylor says groped her during a 2013
photo op before this Denver constable
Mueller however testified in front of an
eight-person jury that there was no
groping he says his closed fist with the
palm down came in contact with a part of
Swift's body he said quote I felt what
seemed to be a rib cage or ribs and then
he held his hand up so that everyone
could see what he was talking about so
what's next in the trial well we expect
Taylor to take the stand in the next few
days as the defense begins its case
now we also expect to hear from a
photographer and assistant tailors tour
manager and a bodyguard who were all at
that meet-and-greet when the alleged
incident took place
[Music]
you